[Music]  you've been gifted this beautiful house  we live here  can you believe it  [Music]  they've wanted to keep the place in your  family jamie  we really appreciate the house  well then you know  it's got a hole in the roof the wheels  they'll do a good job jamie  you just carry on with your day as if we  weren't here  there is one thing i need to show you  and it's a little bit peculiar  every evening before sunset she'd leave  a blood offering here sorry did you say  blood  for who  for the red caps  [Music]  they'll need feeding  you'll be hungry  can i get in my own house please your  own idea how many times have the english  come to this country and tell us what  areas is now theirs  they need to know their place  what did you leave out tonight oh shoot  you can't miss a single day  hello  is anyone there  i can't be scared i'm not in my own  house  don't leave your wrists alone with the  lads  [Music]  every day  every day  we just came here for some peace  [Music]  you